[Music]
hello and welcome to the beyond us
series by the institute of art and ideas
my name is bernardo castro and my name
is fred
matzer throughout the beyond the series
we've explored four concepts that
underpin
and define the modern world knowledge
competition language and growth
and in each episode we've been joined by
a leading thinker
to help us and hopefully our audience
see each concept in a new light
we've had rebecca goatstein on knowledge
donald hoffman on competition jennifer
horn's beyond language
and more galdot on growth and
in this bonus episode bernardo and i
are going to be reflecting on the series
as a whole
discussing the views of our guests and
seeing
if we have come to any new conclusions
of our own
there's a great big gap between
what we can prove you know
mathematically
logically uh you know a priori proof
um the empirical evidence we have
and our view of the world what we need
in order to orient ourselves in this
reality so fred in our discussion with
rebecca i think the points that uh
shone through mostly were an emphasis
on skepticism the idea that to have
reliable knowledge we have to doubt what
we think we know
we have to question what we think we
know sort of
kick the tires of knowledge so to say so
we don't
fool ourselves because of our you know
wishful thinking or you know
gullible tendencies or whatever i think
that's a good point she emphasized
reason as a means of transcendence
and i think that was also a very strong
point she made the idea that
our reason can help us transcend
the ordinary limits of human knowledge
that through reasoning we can go beyond
immediate experience and extract
conclusions
about things like you know the depth of
the universe
black holes and quasars and the
microscopic world of quantum phenomena
that would otherwise be unreachable
to our knowledge so she emphasized that
as well
and one thing that i thought but that's
my own opinion
a little less on the mark
so to say but that's again my own
opinion
is that she came across
as indicating that feeling
and intuition um are not reliable
um she established a contrast she said
okay it's feeling and intuition are less
reliable than
reason and empirical experimentation or
science
of course there is some truth to that
but i felt that
she underestimated the importance of
reason and intuition how do you see that
yeah well thank you for asking bernardo
i think
it was quite interesting for me to see
that rebecca associated transcendence in
the development of
of knowledge as something that is
yeah a a augmentation through the mental
faculty that
yeah perhaps brings us what i often say
beyond
the curtain that is an interesting view
that from my experience i cannot really
confirm that it works that way
what i know about that what we express
knowledge in words and numbers is that
it's a strong tool to communicate
and to develop knowledge which is very
useful
as we see in all kind of applications in
in society
but on the other hand i'm aware that
everything that expresses itself in
words
is always following some information
that anticipates the expression
and the way i look at the feeling
and the intuitive faculty for me
is very reliable because it is the
inner world that brings my consciousness
to certain things that i
by at a later instant can express
in words so yes in that respect i have a
different view
it is important to listen to the
products of our mind
that are expressed mentally but as
important and for me even more
important is that that what comes to our
feeling
uh is is a
very important component in our decision
making process
and experience there is a
a tendency in our cultural itos today
and i think since the late 19th century
to to neglect feeling and intuition
isn't there to
to me it's this sounds like
a psychic amputation i mean our psyche
has
many functions or faculties as you refer
to them
not only reasoning we do have intuition
we do have
feelings emotions things that can inform
our lives sometimes
you can't really coherently argue why
you think a certain thing but your
intuition is screaming
and that is right and sometimes it's
important to listen to that isn't it
even if it's not entirely reliable uh it
shouldn't be neglected should it
no i no as saying i said it is
very important and what i observe is
yes as children and also later on
we are trained to trust
our our mental faculty we have
schools kindergarten university
everything
that teaches us in in the use of the
mental faculty but also in the trust
of that use and its
sister the feeling and intuitive faculty
yes we allow it to be there
but we see perhaps the mental faculty as
the super league
while the feeling faculty is something
nice is like saturday late afternoon
soccer playing you know
and uh i would uh definitely uh
invite everybody to to
allow more trust in your feelings
because it's the inner voice
and indeed the mental products can be
shared and that's also why it is so
important feeling is much more difficult
to share in words it can be it can be
shared in
songs in playing music sometimes in art
it's
it's worthless but not worthless how do
we do that fred how do we
get to a point where we can listen
enough to the to the intuitive and the
feeling faculty
to a point where we can rely on them and
not be
fooled by them i think by training our
brain to calm down
to reduce our stress to listen to
classical music
to learn to meditate and
those techniques have helped you those
techniques have helped me
and not all the time but most of the
time
walking in nature can help too i confess
to having difficulty i mean i i'm
entirely with you
in in my opinion about what's going on i
think we should not amputate
to extraordinarily important and i would
say even more fundamental more
primordial mental
or psychic faculties and rely entirely
on reasoning
but i have difficulties sorting through
what my
intuition and my feelings tell me
sometimes
sometimes i think they are fooling me
but i do have a sense for when it's
reliable
there is a how to say an ineffable
quality
to an intuition when it's the reliable
one
it's like you just know it and even if
you
tell yourself a story well i can't rely
on it it just comes with a certain
weight
that is very difficult to resist and to
me that's that's the
the hallmark of reliable intuition when
it comes with that
force of trust you know that's a certain
gravitas to it
yeah thank you and i also struggle with
it many many many times a day
but my experience over the decades is
as long as the intuition is an intuition
that
serves more in the whole and all the
more reliable
it is when it is a
more like a feeling of
fear closer to the ego
it's that you have to be on your guard
yes it might serve you on an individual
level
but the the richness and the depth of
the feeling
is bigger when it is closer to the
interest
of the creation so to say
there is something you said earlier that
i i can relate a lot
to you said the feeling and the
intuition come
first and then the reasoning faculty
sort of
follows from that and then tries to give
words to
it and communicate it even communicate
it to ourselves tell ourselves in words
what we feel
or what we intuit i can relate to that
even in my
work on philosophy i i clearly see
that the intuition of the answer
to a question or a problem i'm
struggling with struggling with
that intuition comes first and
only thereafter i can reason it
out sort of kick the tires through
reason and say okay now this this holds
water this stands up to
to scrutiny uh but the intuition comes
first
and i wonder whether this perhaps isn't
the case for everybody even
rebecca herself uh that the intuition
comes first and then we sort of reason
it
out and then we think that it came from
reason but in fact it has a different
origin
what do you think yeah and i think as
earlier mentioned we have not been
taught
to rely on our intuition
so we use often go uh send it overboard
all right this sums up uh our summary
and views
uh on on the first episode we will move
now to
our fantastic conversation with
professor donald hoffman
on competition you can think of your
body in that sense as
quadrillions of organisms separate each
cell is an organism
that have agreed to cooperate
not to fight cancer are our cells that
have sort of
decided to break the pact and several
things came through in our conversation
with
donald that i think and i'm sure you
think so too
uh fred are key
are central uh to our ability to
progress as a culture closer to
ourselves closer to to truth
um one of the things he always
emphasizes
and which i think it it's you know
although he has had
math to prove it he has had all kinds of
simulations to prove it
it is something that we should all
intuit and that links back to the first
episode
which is that perception does not
offer us direct access to reality
we think that what we see what we hear
what we smell taste and touch the screen
of our perception
we think that it's some kind of
transparent
windshield into the world as it as it is
in itself but of course that's not
what evolution would have done evolution
would have created
a dashboard of dials for us to collect
information about the external world in
a way that favors
survival and not in a way that favors
transparent access to the truth
of the matter so what we see here and
smell
these are just dials on a dashboard
and the world as it is in itself it's
something different
it's as different as the storm outside
is different from the instrument panel
of a pilot flying a plane through the
storm
and i think this is a key insight
because it tells us
that what we call matter surrounding us
it is not the world as it is in itself
it's not fundamental it's just an
appearance
it's the dials it's the virtual reality
the world as it is in itself is
not material and it's probably more like
a mental processes conscious processes
even though not our personal
mental processes and uh
although i think this is something we
should all apprehend
very intuitively uh professor professor
hoffman
i'll call him dawn he's a friend so not
pretend not to know him
dawn always emphasizes that we should
have a mathematically precise
theory and that's a bit of a concession
to our current
cultural ethos that unless
you can dress everything up in
mathematical equations
it's not really true that's not what
dawn means what dawn means is you have
to be precise
in order to for others to be able to
judge whether you're right or whether
you're wrong you have to specify
precisely what you say
and i agree with that but there is an
intuitive flow behind it or
underneath it that suggests that things
are not real unless we can model them
there i'm partly sympathetic with that
because of education but i'm not fully
uh on board with that
and then finally professor hoffman dawn
uh
drove to a conclusion that i think his
music to your ears
fred which is that what we call scar
city
lack that these things may
too be artifacts of the virtual reality
of the instrument panel
that in the world in the world as it is
in itself there may be
no scarcity in which case scarcity would
be an illusion that that's very close to
your thought
isn't it fred if we see
uh the finite world
as an expression of infinity then
it is a that's a universe of matter
matter that expresses itself from high
densities
deep in the earth for example to
uh set to the most subtle fields of
energy
at the edges of our universe
but if we would for example would give
every form of matter whatever
dense or not the name of particle or
cell or whatever
we would see that everything co exists
next to all the other elements so
it is a collection an ever moving
collection
that goes from high density to low
density
and that we can observe or connect with
through our human senses for example or
even beyond it
so if i relate it to the subject
of scarcity then i say scarcity
is a view in this case a human view
where you want to see that something
lacks but that means that you first make
a choice in your mind
what lacks so that's a choice and that
you already take
out of the whole so in that way i try to
say
yes it is an attitude but if you
try to get everything in your mind you
could always also
come to a different conclusion
to scarcity relates competition but you
can also say
well that is let us cooperate
and compare with care in order to share
with care
so that what you once have may have seen
as scarcity is a
impetus to deal differently
with scarcity from the understanding
that everything
is inclusive don's key point is that
evolution by natural selection which of
course entails
competition creatures competing against
each other
for for say limited resources that it is
that competition
that leads to the virtual reality that
leads to
the notion that we do not see the world
as it is in itself because evolution
would have given us
a dashboard an instrument panel and not
a transparent windscreen
into the world so we could compete
better and survive
that that's the the key drive of his
argument that evolution by natural
selection does
it does not offer us a window into the
truth it just helps us survive
and then as a consequence of that
argument he also says
okay but if then we are living in a
virtual reality
if we are flying by instrument so to say
without a glass windshield to see the
world outside
as it really is then scarcity
itself could be just an artifact
of the dashboard of the virtual reality
but that leads to sort of a circle
doesn't it
because to some extent evolution
leverages competition competition for
resources
but evolution may also lead to the
illusion of scarcity which is the basis
of competition could this be a sort of
the vicious circle in which one thing
uh gives rise to the other and circular
circularly so
could scarcity be the result of a kind
of
circular process in nature that in fact
is not
really there it's just an artificial
conclusion from a certain
dynamics of the system i agree
so indeed it's it it is the
snake that bites in the end its own tail
so if if you what is happening if you
would allowed it to meet with your
ever higher consciousness through
developing consciousness
you will see that it has been there
perhaps to
serve you to make yeah in life in a
material life
more efficient choices to survive
but when you go through the layer of
survival
you may discover something else and what
i
mentioned in the beginning by
lowering down your brain rhythm you will
see for example that you become more
conscious
that you need less food that
nurturing comes also through drinking
water
and taking in air on on an
efficient way and that you
will find fulfillment in your life
that doesn't express itself linearly but
transcendent one of the things
i always have a metaphor that i keep it
to my mind a metaphor you told me
years ago that i've found fantastic um
in our culture today we seem to even be
educated
for competing you know children go to
piano lessons at least in europe very
early on and when they're
five in order to you know make two two
how to say to be better than their peers
in primary school and then we
we go through life competing we compete
at school compete at university compete
in our jobs
uh compete against our peers for a for a
partner it seems to be
built into our culture but one day you
told me look
the the the pure and natural
impetus that we associate with
competition
is actually something else and you use
that metaphor of
playing ping-pong which resonated with
me a lot
because i played ping pong a lot when i
was a kid and and
i played when i played ping pong as a
kid i didn't want to win
i wanted to keep the ball in play
because that's how i would have the most
fun
i wanted to push my opponent to
to his or her edge but not win because
the moment i would score a point the
game would stop and it wouldn't be fun
no indeed and that that that i i don't
know but at a certain moment i saw that
that indeed in the very beginning
and i didn't talk about ping pong with
tennis i realized that tennis was
it was developed to express
the fun and the pleasure of the
continuation of the flow
so you together are a cycle you
develop the game in such a way that you
help the other
person to stretch so that that person
can return the ball
instead of break the cycle and at the
later stage
i don't know i often make a little joke
i don't know if you've seen it but
they award or reward the person that
breaks the cycle
so the person that doesn't do the
continuum and and
that is the example for me how we
have arranged our society it's by
exclusion and those people
that are successful in the excluding
others being
in their mind or the world's mind number
one they are
awarded but it always implies a winner
and a loser
look at how the loser will feel i mean
the society cannot have all winners to
the detriment of how many losers does
that go
what is the lost energy in
so many people by creating that system
okay these are our reflections on
competition and then we had a discussion
with jennifer hornsby about
language if you're a student of language
or linguistics or philosophy of language
or whatever
you take this phenomenon of exchange of
information and then realize a whole lot
more can go on
simply exchange of information can be
given etc etc
feelings expressed um but of course
that's never all that's going on when
language is used
according to jennifer language is
something objective because it is shared
we sort of
share meaning share intent
by giving words to it and
that sharing renders its objective
renders language uh objective
and this drive to objectivity relates to
to
reasoning to the to the to the mental
faculty as you refer
uh to it uh fred and the
jennifer argues then that uh although
language sort of you know
stems from us as subjective beings it is
it is the collective character of dutch
of that sharing of meaning that
renders it objective and not purely
personal
and idiosyncratic um she goes to the
point of saying that
insofar as language sort of
dresses experience even our
consciousness in so far again insofar as
it's dressed by language
even our consciousness is not really
only an inner world
it becomes externalized through language
and
and therefore it is rendered objective
and so there is this
push towards objectification
of what is by birth subjective
this movement from the inside to the
outside
which takes the form of language
and and she goes on to say that the
meaning of
words and language structures because of
this objectification
that meaning isn't really relative
that there is a absolute meaning
to things that are said provided they
are said of course
correctly
i think this view is very
compatible at least it sort of evokes
our present
cultural ethos that attempt to
render everything objective and
therefore reliable
uh it echoes our mistrust
of subjectivity of our idiosyncratic
personal intuition and and feelings
so this movement from the inside to the
outside
from the personal to the collective from
the subjective to the objective
you see that again not only in the first
episode but in the
third episode perhaps especially in the
third
episode i respect
that view fred but my personal view is
that
it goes too far it may be
i don't use this word pejoratively but
it may be in a sense naive
because my own experience in philosophy
for instance
is that the meaning we give to words
is very difficult to objectify
we sometimes miscommunicate a lot talk
past each other because our respective
understandings of what particular
words mean differ and therefore it's not
quite objective maybe
words would be objective in an ideal
world but i think we are very
far away from that ideal world
and i also feel that this
seeming uh tendency in our culture and
i'm not speaking about jennifer only but
this
the seeming tendency in our culture to
crush
the subjective to crush the
idiosyncratic
it may translate into an attempt to
crush
reality because subjectivity is the only
carrier of reality we know and can know
isn't it how do you see this
yes thank you bernardo while you were
talking i
thought about how important it is when
we speak
to listen to the intonation of the
spoken words
the way i express myself
hopefully it's a way of how i feel on
one side
and in the meantime see it as a means
to reach out to you and later on to the
audience
and build a bridge build a bridge of
communication
so in a way i see
language and the inclusion of words
and and numbers in language as a tool to
communicate
information
as such they are yeah they are just part
of my toolkit
and of other other people took it very
useful
but beyond the language i can
i can sense more ways of communicating
than just using the words and the
intonation of the words
sometimes smells or uh
expressions in faces or gestures with
hands it all
helps to yeah bring people closer or
further away
we run a big risk in our culture doesn't
we
to to lose a lot of things in
translation
from feeling to words we we judge people
by what they say
as opposed to what they mean or how they
feel from the inside
don't we yeah that's even another
subject
and as you know better than i do you can
follow all kind of courses how you can
hide yourself
and and manipulate people with your
thoughts because you want to serve a
certain interest which is completely
made of may be disassociated from you
because you
play a role losing your own authenticity
and it links back to our discussion on
competition because
if we focus on what people say as
opposed to what they mean
if we spot a flaw in their linguistic
argument
line we seize on that to crush the crush
and invalidate
the other person because we sort of want
to be better we want to compete and
win uh and and in the process of doing
that
the real meaning what the intended
meaning
the the inner reality that tried to
express itself outside
it just flies over our hands we miss out
on that and
i i fear that we may be missing out on
so much
that we would panic if we really
understood how much we are missing out
on
yeah and indeed we have a choice well in
the
in the example you just use when you try
to abuse the person that in its
words apparently doesn't reflect
expressing
the meaning you can also have the choice
do i hear this correctly because i see
you may mean something else and if it's
in my interest
or not doesn't matter please try
again and i'll help you to
express better what you meant to say
and you would be enriched by that
because that's the different attitude
you have a choice you know
and it also links back to the very first
episode on on
you know reason uh knowledge through
reason
um which is that um i sense
that in our culture um now in the ethos
of our culture today
we think that whatever cannot be
articulated in logical words
whatever cannot be described in words or
explained in words
then it doesn't exist we think that
whatever does exist
has to be amenable to description or
articulation through words
and whatever you cannot describe in
words the ineffable
then it doesn't exist but there is no
logic behind this link is there who
whoever said that what cannot be said
cannot exist
yeah no i mean two steps i wanted to
make with
all of us and that go back let's go back
to the childhood when the child doesn't
have the use of word
it still exists and it communicates
information
through all the senses doesn't have the
vocabulary yet
and as long as we respect the love in
the child
and in ourselves we can definitely
communicate
and think on the other end of life where
often
people develop alzheimer's and they
cannot express themselves well anymore
still consciousness is running through
them
and we want we are not going to exclude
these people
they suffer from something they are
different
and yes we try to keep them in the loop
of our society
so often they lose the words
and still are aware and it would be
really sad if we would just
ignore these two groups and their faith
could be ours
tomorrow uh and then presumably we
wouldn't
like other people to think that because
we cannot
word things we cannot give language to
things
that we no longer have an inner life
right
presumably wouldn't we wouldn't like
that to be done to us
and yet we have this tendency in our
culture you know this drive
for reliability and objectivity which
sort of emphasizes
the the the rational faculty
and language over feeling subjective
impression
intuition it runs the risk of
eliminating the only carrier of reality
we know which is
our own ineffable subjectivity
right we sort of run a very serious risk
in the way we are going with our culture
today yeah
and then what i'm thinking of now bring
a master in uh say
a chinese language together with a
latino that's a master in the latino
language
bring them for one week on an island
they have two fantastic languages
but you won't be able to use them
and then we went on to have a fantastic
conversation with mo galdat i i
personally
enjoyed that conversation a lot i know
from you we talked afterwards i know
that you've enjoyed it as well we both
have a very very good impression
of mo i think he's doing important work
in the world today and that discussion
was about
growth the question really is how much
of it is
enough and what's the price we pay for
it how much is enough
is a very very interesting question do
we need an
iphone 13 and if the if the
if the price of the iphone cell 13 is
going to be
horrendous impact on the planet and your
stress level and your life and so on
maybe then we don't and it links back
to what we just talked about which is
this tendency to
objectify everything at the cost of our
subjectivity which is the only carrier
of reality we have
and what mo said is that often
what is most valuable cannot be measured
in other words cannot be quantified or
objectified
because what we do with words we also do
with numbers
and especially in the hard sciences if
you cannot
model something with numbers then it
doesn't exist
it's not part of nature it's not reality
um
so i detect here this the same tendency
that that that we discussed
about the three three previous episodes
this idea that
growth is about an increase in some
numerical
quantity and that's precisely what moe
said we shouldn't do because we will
miss out
on what is most valuable if we if we do
this if we go after only the things that
can be measured and whose numeric value
increases he also said
at least suggested that you know our
consumerist society you know riding on
capitalism
um focuses precisely
on this numerical growth you know growth
of
a return on investment growth in your
bank account salo growth in
the number of partners you've had in
your life
and he he said that okay if we continue
to pursue these
growing quantities this will come at the
cost of the planet because
the planet is not growing and whether
you measure growth
quantitatively or qualitatively the
planet is not growing
so a society or a civilization within
it cannot keep on growing forever unless
and until we expand to some
to some other planet um so for him that
was a big risk and i completely agree
with him
capitalism as we implement it today
emphasizes this notion of growth so much
that there is even this adage that
companies that don't grow
are dead companies i mean where
is this going because the planet is not
growing
uh if we have a system that depends on
numerical growth
only uh we are walking straight uh into
oblivion
so for for for mo we should focus also
or perhaps predominantly on
qualitative growth growth in
happiness happiness is a quality not a
quantity
uh we should look at you know
psychological
qualities as opposed to purely material
growth the growth in the quality of our
relationships
the growth and the quality of our
experiences of the events of our lives
and he suggested that happiness
has to do with this growth in quality
that
if the qualitative result of something
is higher
than our expectations about it then we
are happy so for him this whole thing is
is a qualitative psychological dynamics
and not a numerical game and i know fred
that
you uh wholeheartedly agree with it
doesn't you
yes i do and um yeah
i think indeed in the whole business
world
growth is a word that has
been hijacked from natural growth
growth that happens in nature at
the patient time of nature
we cannot speed it up nor slow it down
nature has its own rhythm but we hijack
growth
indeed in a quantitative sense with the
detrimental effects
on the real growth so the whole process
of conception growth decaying and death
we are disturbing by intervening in that
natural
cycle and by doing so we
miss out indeed as you described in
reciting bo
a mo is that we miss out on the
quality of xd experience of happiness of
the experience of
joy of the experience of forgiving of
the experience of
sharing all those lovely things that
we miss because our mental faculty is so
occupied
that we don't allow our feeling faculty
those
wonderful experiences you've been
a very successful business person
according to the values and prejudices
of our society today
you are a very very very successful
person
because i'm not aware of that but this
is this is what i wanted to ask you
um if one would look at your bank
account people would say well you're
very successful because
you've grown a lot in an on a numerical
basis but you have had the experience of
it so you have
authority to say it does that
quantitative growth
leave a lead to happiness in your life
for sure not that alone for sure not
so getting rich is not the answer is it
no i think it's
important to of course uh
when you're poor and you're more or less
excluded from the economic system
it's a different answer so yes i can
only answer for myself so
i if i would give an advice to people
now
in living in the netherlands where i do
live is you know
stop when you have your first first two
or three million then it's enough you
know i mean
but for most people this is a dream
right even a
huge huge yeah dream so
yeah money doesn't make me happy but the
lack of money can make you very
unhappy we have this idea that
if only we get that amount of money then
all problems would be solved but
based on my own experiences i mean i'm
not nearly as successful
as you but i'm not a poor person and my
own experience in that sort of rat race
is that at some point you realize
that you're chasing ghosts once you have
enough to leave safely
and comfortably the next step is usually
a ghost and when you catch it you run
your fingers through it and you realize
that
it was nothing it doesn't make you happy
anymore
no and also now that you talk about it
when i go through the process of life
yes in my earlier part of life i was
less rested in myself
less secure so i was although i didn't
want to
tell or say or be honest about it but i
was more dependent
on confirmation from the outside world
and the more i developed my
consciousness the more i had the chance
to be be more authentic and rest more in
myself
and be less dependent on all those other
things that other people so often are
keep on being dependent on
and you alluded first that our
the word growth was sort of um we got it
from nature
but then we sort of um
we abused it we made it mean
something that it didn't originally mean
and the image i have in my mind is a
seed right or an acorn
that grows into an oak but that's
qualitative growth right it's not only
quantitative growth
you see just the quality of the
transformation
of the forms and the vital stuff
going through the system and so that we
can enjoy the fruits of beauty
and of nutrition so if we if we say okay
we don't need to grow our bank accounts
out of uh beyond a certain value
um what how should we grow then what is
this
qualitative growth that we should pursue
well this perhaps is also a little bit
surprising what i'm going to say the
growth
in essence for me is the growth
in the sense of the development of
consciousness
for example to understand
that the
cycle of conception
growth decay and death
in itself doesn't conceive grow
decay nor dies
and that indicates that there is a power
beyond that cycle and that in my
experience
is a huge loving power
which many people call god
and that is the ultimate understanding
in my way
in my view and based on some
profound experience as well
so growth in nature it's not only
the the growth in size of an acorn into
an oak
but it's also the decline of the acorn
it is also the
ultimate death of the acorn and we sort
of excluded
that asp those aspects of growth from
our
cultural notion of what growth means
right yeah we
it's not so pleasant to talk about death
or decay
so we lose interest so we all focus on
young
and growing but that's not
reality in totality so the real growth
is in the understanding of the certain
or the different stages
of life and death so we
grow into older selves we grow
into death qualitatively but we don't
see that as growth anymore
well i hope it will return back on stage
and then we will always grow throughout
life
fred this has been a fantastic journey
uh
with you first and foremost uh with the
four guests
we've had i hope you the listener
has enjoyed it as well i hope you have
grown
from this experience i certainly have i
suspect
fred has grown a little bit too from
this and
i hope to see you next time with some
other series
thank you very much and take care yeah
and i want to thank you bernardo my
friend very much for
having such a wonderful dialogue
together
i hope our audience will enjoy it and
has enjoyed it after this
seeing this and also want to thank very
much
the wonderful team at iai for facility
facilitating us thank you so much
and miles of smiles to everybody
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today
to the institute of art and ideas at iai
tv
you